be me for a second would you trust you
the answer is no
well if you didn't let me be you here
Germany sorry for always being so hard
on you it's only because I love you I
don't talk like that when Harrison said
that he would do it and I saw the
announcement I thought it was a
practical joke it seemed unreal that you
wanted to do this show with me oh man
come on well that's really true and I'm
sure at some point
this is my everyday
[Music]
sit on Jimmy if I sit down and want to
feel like I'm in trouble you are in
trouble he wanted John Wayne but they
were disappointed here about his
you know the most important person in
your life is right now you know you
your daughter right that's what I meant
I'm second
okay in all seriousness I've always
admired his work the writing is uh
fantastic and the relationship is to me
really funny and interesting he doesn't
think so but I do
can we talk I don't need another lecture
it's about Gabby oh I was kind of
looking forward to a fight yeah I could
tell these two guys they have a mentor
mentee relationship but I think it's
also a surrogate father-son relationship
Jimmy desperately wants Paul's approval
you just said you love me no I did not
well it sounded like you did
I think Paul has really complicated
relationship with his kids and sees
Jimmy as potentially a son so the show
is all about lines being blurred
and I think that the Paul Jimmy
relationship is a real example of that
I've known you for years I've never met
your daughter yeah what is she like she
lives in Connecticut
I'll
it's like she's in the room
the character that Jason Plays is
complex and uh visceral and exciting the
relationship comes from the writers but
there also is a personal relationship
that that fuels me who knows how you
grieve you haven't even begun what are
you talking about I've been grieving for
a year no
you've been known
I'm worried about you it's the kind of
material where I don't know from one
moment to the next whether I'm going to
laugh or cry I feel enormously lucky to
just be part of this thing same and I
think it's good for people to laugh you
should see Harrison Ford do comedy not
today
do you know what percentage of yourself
is actually made of water I know what
percentage of me doesn't give it okay
well that's the dehydration talking
yeah
let's go
[Music]